oui j'ai abandonné mes étudiants j'ai un
petit peu route
je leur ai dit de regarder donc à quoi
sert un étudiant en art à quoi servent
les écoles d'art à quoi servent les
études en art et à quoi sert l'art
toutes ces questions je vais pas y
répondre
je veux absolument pas de vraies
réponses mais on va tourner autour du
pot et puis peut-être que ça vous
donnera des idées alors la première
chose c'est ted
c'est assez bizarre pour moi de me
retrouver ici je me suis toujours
demandé ce que vous êtes peut-être en
france si c'était vraiment adapté parce
qu'un esprit très très positive toujours
vachement optimiste tout et on va
arranger le monde tout va être
formidable et j'ai jamais vraiment cru
ça va toujours rappeler de panpan sommes
pleins vous connaissez dans un bambi qui
a une phrase un moment il dit if you
can't say something like donc c'est
henning alors si vous savez pas dire de
gentils chose nous dit très haut et on
s'est tellement pas français comme
manière de penser qu'on n'arrive même
pas à le traduire dans le dvd et on a
traduit si tu sais pas dire les gentils
chose part si tu sais dire que des
méchancetés
nous on est dans un esprit voltairien
sahiron des tests d'abord on discute
ensuite et puis en dernier
éventuellement se renseignent comme vous
connaissez par exemple le célèbre
philosophe alain finkielkraut qui a
écrit un livre il ya 15 ans contre
internet
j'ai vu dans une interview récente qui
disait qu'on allait peut-être l'amener
sur internet il allait bientôt voir à
quoi ça ressemble il a déjà écrit un
livre l'effroyable extra s'appelait il
ya 15 ans mais bon j'ai décidé de jouer
le jeu et au contraire d'être positif et
optimiste et de parme et de des
étudiants j'aime beaucoup les étudiants
en art j'ai été moi même et puis voilà
j'en ai plein depuis quelques années
maintenant là vous voyez des photos
d'étudiants que je suis allé interviewer
maintenant je retourne interviewer mes
étudiants chez un petit blog le dessus
et je leur demande comment ça va voilà
on en reparlera alors l'école donc
l'école cash fait de mes 16 ans la cité
pas mes 16 ans et mes maîtresses en 14
ans je suis plus 14 je n'étais pas fait
pour le collège vous voyez dans ma
période punk
donc je réessaye voilà ici avec derrière
moi madame thévard c'était ma prof de
maths et elle était très gentil le
notamment elle me permettait de dessiner
en cours j'avais le droit de dessiner
chez elle j'avais pas le brand en
français en histoire géo j'avais pas le
bon en arts plastiques de dessiner mais
mes schémas mt var j'avais deux cahiers
1 pour les matins pour le dessin où je
gribouillais comme je voulais et ça se
passait très bien j'ai oublié de mettre
le compteur alors pour me faire dg steve
et voilà je suis un conteur et donc aime
laisser gribouillé quand je voulais le
pensait que ça ne faisait pas la
concentration et la psychologie lui a
donné raison en fait ça a été
expérimenté gribouillé aide à se
concentrer en fait pas dessinée destinée
ça on se concentre sur son dessin mais
gribouillé cède ça aide à se concentrer
voilà mais bon j'étais pas fait pour le
collège alors on m'a orienté dans el
pais pousse à tous que c'est peut-être
je suis parti faire un certificat
d'aptitude professionnelle on retouche
photo vous connaissez la retouche photo
à l'époque personne ne savait ce que
c'était et moi je pensais que c'est ce
qui va me permettre de rentrer chez
industrial light and magic se c'était 2
pour ce faire les effets spéciaux de
star voir chez george lucas mais ça
n'est pas arrivé
ça s'est pas passé comme ça à l'époque
on utilisait un pinceau will la photo de
droite qui est très malheureux touché
j'ai regardé derrière la note c 4 sur 20
c'est ma meilleure banque la cgt pas non
plus fait pour ça mais bon j'ai appris
des choses mais donc ont retouché au
pinceau ou au crayon et puis finalement
c'est c'était assez compliqué mais c'est
un métier que les gens connaissaient pas
il n'avait pas de visibilité
aujourd'hui n'importe quel gamin salle
utiliser des logiciels de retouche vous
en avez même parfois dans vos téléphones
et nos profs nous disait ah vous verrez
un jour la photo ça sera sur ordinateur
aura des appareils numériques pour le
moment la définition est pas bonne enfin
il nous disait qu'on verrait peut-être
ça d'autres vivent quoi et puis quatre
ans plus tard sont arrivés les premiers
logiciels de prépresse enfin se sont
généralisés tous les logiciels qui ont
bouleversé la chaîne graphique et qui
ont fait disparaître énormément de
métier disparaître ou transformés en
tout cas tout ce qu'on avait appris
servait à rien la retouche photo
typiquement voilà mon épouse en quelques
semaines après avoir utilisé les
premiers logiciels de retouche était
bien meilleur que moi qui avait passé
trois ans à être formés à ça mais j'ai
appris quand même à faire des choses
c'était plutôt plaisant de faire ses
études
j'appris avoir les mains propres on
retouche faut tourner le budget d'avoir
les mains toujours très propre ce qui
m'a servi aux beaux-arts un petit peu
plus tard mais bon voilà j'avais été
ajustés comme comme un écrou pour un
boulon
donc pour un écrou comme vous voulez a
un métier qui a disparu donc les métiers
disparaissent et ça ne cessera d'arrivée
c'est le destin des métiers à part
quelques métiers vraiment artisanaux
très très spécifiques
finalement il vaut mieux se former à
apprendre apprendre à apprendre plutôt
qu'à être formé pour une chose très très
précis alors l'enseignement donc je suis
rentré aux beaux-arts après j'ai réussi
à rentrer au bozar sans le bac c'était
la dernière année où on pouvait sur le
bac j'ai toujours pas le bac
voilà mais maintenant on peut plus
rentrer aux beaux-arts de paris sans le
bac et là j'ai vu que tout le monde a
vraiment dégoûtant les gens un travail
très salma et puis bon voila j'ai fait
mon service national et j'ai voulu
rentrer à la fac pour je vais pas trop
pourquoi les beaux-arts me plaisait pas
trop parce que j'avais un petit mépris
pour mon chef d'atelier
je trouvais que c'était pas très bien ce
qu'ils faisaient je pensais à l'époque
pour faire un bon prof il fallait un bon
artiste que seul un bon artiste
rayonnait sur ces étudiants et on
faisait voilà et on faisait de bons
artistes même alors qu'en fait non il ya
des très mauvaises artistes qui font
d'excellents prof
il ya aussi des bons artistes qui font
des bons profs les malheureusement
demeure artistes qui font d'elles des
mauvais profs tout ça existe mais donc
voilà en arrivant à la fac je suis tombé
sur une équipe qui s'occupait
d'interactivité de nouveaux médias en
arrêtent tout et ça me paraissait
vraiment dégoûtant moi j'aimais bien la
peinture
et l'idée qu'on mélange l'ordinateur que
pourtant j'aimais beaucoup
j'avais un ordinateur et l'art ça me
paraissait pas normal ça c'est une expo
récente de jacques père comptes qui a
rien à voir avec mes étudiants mais qui
montre bien le pixel est la picturalité
j'aime bien ces images mais donc voilà
je comprenais pas trop l'idée mais j'ai
quand même suivi des cours par par
curiosité
et puis finalement ça m'a beaucoup plu
est assez vite comme j'ai des les autres
étudiants puisque j'étais plutôt doué
pour la programmation on m'a confié des
charges de cours et puis de là je suis
devenu prof en école d'art est bien et
puis dans plein d'autres villes comme
rennes est maintenant au havre voilà
donc ça c'était pour raconter un peu ma
vie du coup je suis déjà très enfin j'ai
dû prendre beaucoup de temps déjà
être seul média puissant vous allez voir
je tourne autour du point je vous
raconte pas exactement j'ai pas un
discours très structuré même si ça a
l'air puisque un diaporama
mais être samuel était plus en voilà
qu'il ya une chose intéressant vous
connaissez ces émissions de coaching qui
sont des émissions dans lesquelles on
apprend finalement être adapté au monde
on apprend à s'habiller d'une manière
qui font que les autres vont vous
regardez bien on apprend à aménager sa
maison de manière à ce qu'ils étaient de
livres puisque c'est très mal vu
on apprend à recevoir les gens leur
faisons des animations et puis on
apprend si on a des problèmes de j'ai
pas de rangement et tout elle voilà tout
ça c'est assez positif en fait c'est
assez épuisant de vivre parmi de ses
semblables
puisque finalement voilà dans la société
on a besoin d'eux un petit peu de se
fondre dans la masse ça peut même aller
très loin
comme j'adore le rapport entre le slogan
est l'image jouer c'est devenez vous
même
donc on vous dit que vous devenez vous
même mais en fait on vous font dans le
treillis vous devenez un bout de
camouflage vous êtes tout le contraire
de vous même vous êtes à une position
vous saurez qui est au dessus de vous
qui en dessous vous vous êtes plus une
personne vous êtes finalement un objet
dans voilà dans une dernière archi mais
c'est intéressant de mettre ce slogan
qui exactement le contraire quoi mais
parce qu'il ya énormément de pub qui
vous propose de devenir vous même soyez
enfin vous même et ses essais à chaque
fois en achetant la même paire de
chaussures que tout le monde le même la
puce vous voyez aujourd'hui en école
d'art en fait le contraire on essaye
c'est pas si facile mais on essaye
d'apprendre à nos étudiants finalement à
s'assumer assumer ce qu'ils font être
fiers de ce qu'ils font à le montrer à
utiliser leur main si à produire des
choses tout ça c'est ce qu'on fait en et
kolda voilà j'ai répondu à la question
sera à quoi sert l'école d'art en gros
fou mais je vais continuer un petit peu
est ce que ça fonctionne est ce que je
pourrais le dire le contraire en fait je
pourrais vous dire aussi qu'on apprend
aux étudiants à vars d'éthique avoir
certaines références culturelles qui
vont faire que il s'intègre mieux dans
justement dans le milieu de l'art etc
mais bon je vais rester positif
est ce que ça fonctionne bien quand je
vous disais je retourne voir mes
étudiants et puis chez les interviewe et
je leur demande s'ils ont une belle vie
en fait c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est
un peu du service après-vente quoi est
bon je leur paye gens payent un coup à
chaque fois alors ils ont l'air tout
souriant mais je pense que même si je
leur pays basque où ils seraient
souriants ils ont l'air contents c'est
pas des disciples ce sont vraiment des
gens que j'ai eu comme étudiant
parfois très peu en fait mais mais voilà
et donc voilà ils sont tout beau et tout
tout heureux de vivre ce qui est assez
gratifiant finalement quand on voit là
et maintenant la grande question à quoi
servent les choses parce que donc je
pose la question à quoi servent les
étudiants en art et on m'a déjà demandé
on m'a dit oui il ya quinze mille
étudiants en art en france
à quoi ça sert de former autant de gens
il n'y a pas de place pour autant
d'artistes et c'est bon mais apparemment
il n'y a pas de place pour grand chose
de toute façon donc autant faire des
choses qui vous plaisent et je vois que
mes étudiants souvent commence par là
ils apprennent la création artistique
moi c'est beaucoup d'étudiants design
design graphique etc mais ils peuvent
aller vers d'autres choses
finalement ce qu'ils ont appris si à
réfléchir un peu indépendamment et puis
c'est très bien alors moi je n'ai pas le
temps de vous expliquer pourquoi je vais
me darwin
mais voilà c'est à propos de l'utilité
des choses par exemple la cravate je
sais pas si beaucoup de cravate
oui le monsieur de gauche c'est un
hussard crois tu en crois tu crois tu se
dit ah fat et donc c'est ce qui a donné
mot cravate
parce que à l'époque de louis xiii
les hussards crois tu qu'ils avaient été
embauchés pour la guerre de trente ans
ne portait pas un jabot infernal dans
lequel se mettaient à la nourriture etc
il avait juste une petite une petite
écharpe assez élégante tout le monde
trouvait ça très joli qui s'appelle
maintenant la cravate
voilà et ça avait un symbole c'était
pour dire voilà on
on a ça parce qu'il ya une femme qui
nous attend au pays on a une épouse et
donc c'est un peu la corde au cou ces
deux c'est ça l'idée mais ce qui est
marrant c'est que ça a beaucoup plus
donc il ya 380 ça a beaucoup plu les
françaises sont mis à mettre la cravate
et puis du coup les anglais ont trouvé
que c'était bien aussi ils ont mis la
cravate est aujourd'hui le salary men
japonais ou chinois porte une cravate et
personne ne sait que c'est un rapport
avec les hussards croit tous enfin on ne
sait pas vraiment où en tout cas en
mettant une cravate les gens n'y pensent
pas mais moi je me suis toujours demandé
à quoi ça servait je déteste la un truc
autour du cou et du coup je ne porte pas
de cravate rouge il quand même ça mais
ça ne sert peuvent plus enfant m'a dit
mais tu as tort de permettre de crainte
c'est un bon moyen de se personnaliser
j'ai toujours trouvé ça bizarre aussi le
leader de ce ce personnalisé se
customiser avoir quelque chose de
personnel dans une norme mais il ya
peut-être une logique
ceci je pourrais avoir raconté
l'histoire d'un croate s'appeler didot
qui est morte ma femme et crois tu donc
je connais des croates qui est allé à
l'enterrement de sa mère avec une
cravate sur laquelle il y avait une
fille nue et ce qui est ce qui est pas
mal et ça montre que effectivement
toutes les cravates ne font pas le même
effet donc voilà la cravate a380 en je
sais pas à quoi sert la cravate mais
doit servir à quelque chose si elle a
survécu 380
je pourrais vous parler de l'agriculture
vous connaissez tous l'agriculture c'est
ce qui a fondé toute notre civilisation
vous veillez l'agriculture ici c'est ce
qui a fait par exemple le travail parce
que quand on
exploite des champs il faut faire
travailler des gens tous en même temps
il faut qu'ils aient plein de gens en
même temps et donc c'est ce qui a permis
d'inventer le travail ça fait beaucoup
de mal à l'humanité qui a perdu 10 ou 20
cm on sait ça parle par les squelettes
parce que le travail finalement est pas
bon pour la santé contrairement à ce
qu'on dit parfois fou surtout le travail
pour d autres enfin voilà c'est ce qui a
permis d' inventions des clôtures
possible ce que si vous avez un champ
exploité
il faut décider à qui vais et puis qui a
le droit de l'exploiter qui peut en
faire quelque chose qui n'a pas le droit
c'est ce qui a permis aussi le mariage
le mariage on sait que c'est une
institution qui est liée à l'agriculture
parce que quand vous avez un champ eh
bien vous voulez transmettre à vos
enfants il faut que la filiation soit
bien identifiée cetera ça sert à ça
le mariage au départ c'est ce qui a
permis l'argent qui permet d'échanger
des biens de nature différente comme
vous savez l'argent les mathématiques
sont nés de là aussi parce qu'il faut
bien compter l'argent l'écriture aussi
puisqu'il faut bien noter ce qu'on a ce
qu on a compté la ville est née avec
l'agriculture la prostitution est né
avec l'agriculture
la carie est arrivé avec l'agriculture
avec les céréales malheureusement la
monarchie au silence et qui avaient pas
droit avant est en fait les rois
viennent de l'agriculture aussi parce
que l'argent et les clôtures permettent
à des gens déjà un orient de pouvoir et
plus que votre est bon pour réfléchir à
tout ça on invente aussi la philosophie
et du plein d'autre chose de tout à fait
positive ça ça à 10 millions c'est pas
mal donc la cravate 391 ans a dit bilan
et ça c'est la grotte de chauvet pousse
donc vous connaissez la grotte de
chauvet en ardèche
je la connais pas tant que je ne connais
que de loin mais qui a été découverte il
ya presque exactement 20 ans dans
quelques semaines ça fera ça fera vingt
ans et où il ya les plus vieux dessins
figuratifs créé par des humains donc des
humains sont mis à dessiner des animaux
qui existait on sait pas du tout à quoi
ça sert c'était peut-être une école
d'art devenue avec plein de gribouiller
pour se préparer à faire d'autres choses
de dehors on sait pas parce que on
connaît que ce qui a survécu dans les
grottes mais elle finalement ce qui a
été peint à l'extérieur dont on ne saura
jamais parce que ça ne peut pas survivre
au temps mais là les conditions font que
ça a survécu il ya des gens qui pensent
que c'était peut-être des installations
multimédias qu'on ne les regardait avec
une torche et puis en passant ça faisait
un peu d'animation quelque chose comme
ça ça a été testé ça c'est plutôt
crédible en fait certaines personnes
vous diront que ces religieux chamanique
etc
j'en sais rien je sais pas quoi sert
l'art mais par contre ça c'est à 35
millions c'est beaucoup plus vieux que
les cravates et beaucoup plus vieux que
finalement que l'agriculture même et
tout ce qui en découle donc vous voyez
l'arrêt on sait pas à quoi ça sert
exactement mais ça doit servir à quelque
chose sévissent toujours de ça existe
depuis vraiment très longtemps voilà je
sais pas si vous avez vu où je voulais
en venir
ça n'a pas vraiment d'importance mais
voilà